Even though cancer was found in my skin, my CA125 score was only a five, which is the
best score I've ever gotten on that test. Is that an indicator that my body has low
inflammation? No, your CA125 is a tumor marker test. Your high sensitivity
reactive protein is an inflammatory test. So a CA125 score of five, that's your
lowest score that you've had on that, tells you that that's an indicator. One
objective finding that your cancer is getting better. So then this is why you
don't even look, you know, okay, the PET scan is the gold standard and we see a
hotspot on your liver. So we need to do something. My question is, do I really? That's
just one indicator. This is where you use your, you know, you have to go through kind
of that question error of yourself, you know, okay, am I more tired than I am? Do I
have any more pain? Do I feel worse? You know, these subjective things are just as
important. So really analyze your body and go, hell, hey, you know, if, if, okay,
if we have a PET scan and it shows some hotspots on your liver or elsewhere in your
brain, does that always mean that, you know, that it is cancer? Well, yes, no, it
doesn't always mean that it's cancer. It's another indicated factor that there's
cancer there. But then you have to weigh that out with other things, your other
subjective findings and your other objective findings. Well, my two markers are
continuing to drop. How can that possibly be? It can be because there always was cancer
there, but it just the PET scan never picked it up before. And it's actually, could be
actually better than it was, you know, six months ago. So it doesn't mean that you need to jump
into another course of care from standards of care protocol or anything like that. You
have to weigh out any objective, fighting with other objective findings and with, I'm feeling,
you know, let's say the case was, hey, my, my C-A125 meeting my other two markers are better.
And I'm actually feeling great. I feel like I had more energy. I don't, you know, I, that
I might say, well, you know, maybe we'll run this test again in three months or six months
or so it, and weigh this all out. You don't just use one test to determine something.
All these things have, have, you know, negatives to them, they can show false positives
and test can show false negatives too. So you want to weigh all these out. You don't want to
put all your eggs in one basket. But again, I would go, you know, have your meeting with
your oncologist, see what they have to say. If they're reasonable and not just a technician of
a practitioner, that they would do the same thing. I think it's what I'm telling you is to be
reasonable. Like, oh, well, this is positive. Could this have been missed before? Yes, the tests,
you know, there's plenty evidence that it could have been missed before. You know, my other tests are
doing well. My blood is doing better. This is doing better. I feel great. I'm sure they're not
going to push you down the course of actions that you don't want to go either. So